russia has now clearly resorted to siege  warfare it has surrounded the city of  mariopol and here in kiev it seems that  russia wants to starve people out this  was one of the country's biggest food  storage facilities and it's completely  destroyed there were 50 000 tons of food  here and the way it worked is food would  come from all over the country  be stored here trucks would pick it up  and then distribute it to the areas all  around kiev  and it wasn't just bombed once this was  no accident you could say well maybe the  russians hit it by accident it's a large  place it was hit twice and then another  food storage facility just about a mile  from here was also attacked so three  strikes seems like it could not have  been a coincidence and that russia is  attacking civilians it's surrounding  cities  and it's trying to starve people